[WIND HOWLING].
♪ ♪
NARRATOR: ANTARCTICA.
IT'S THE LEAST EXPLORED,
LEAST UNDERSTOOD
CONTINENT ON EARTH.
IN WINTER,
THE SUN NEVER RISES.
IN SUMMER,
IT NEVER SETS.
5.4 MILLION SQUARE
MILES OF FROZEN DESERT,
HOME TO THE
DRIEST PLACE ON EARTH.
AVERAGE WINTER TEMPERATURE:
20 TO 90 BELOW.
BARELY ANYTHING
CAN SURVIVE HERE;
NO NATIVE
PEOPLE OR LAND MAMMALS,
NOT EVEN A SINGLE TREE.
BUT IN SPITE OF THE
WORST CONDITIONS ON EARTH,
HUMANITY IS WORKING
TO SCRATCH OUT A PRESENCE.
[CHOPPER].
HEFF: OH, LOOK AT THAT.
DANNY UHLMANN: WOW!
HEFF: THAT IS ONE MOTHER
OF A BLOODY, UH, CREVASSE.
DR. OHNEISER: NOW, WE
ADVANCE ONWARDS INTO NOTHING.
IT'S JUST ICE
SHELF AND HORIZON NOW.
CAPTAIN WALKER: WE'RE
ABOUT TO HIT SOME ICE.
NAVIGATOR:
BRACE FOR SHOCK.
NARRATOR: THE
WORLD'S TOP SCIENTISTS.
DR. FRIEDLAENDER:
THEY'RE REALLY CRYPTIC.
TOTALLY DESIGNED FOR
LIVING IN THE SEA ICE.
NARRATOR: AND THE MEN
AND WOMEN WHO KEEP THEM ALIVE.
TOM ARNOLD: OH, WE'RE
JUST ABOUT TO ENTER INTO
THE SHEAR ZONE HERE.
NARRATOR: JOIN FORCES
TO BATTLE CONDITIONS THAT
THREATEN HUMAN LIFE.
TOM ARNOLD: VISIBILITY'S
DOWN TO 20 METERS.
NARRATOR: THE COLDEST
TEMPERATURE EVER RECORDED:
135.8 DEGREES BELOW ZERO.
AND THE STRONGEST
EVER SUSTAINED WIND:
199 MILES PER HOUR.
[GUSTING WIND]
ALL IN THE NAME
OF RESEARCH...
ROB TEASDALE: HOLD ON!
NARRATOR: THAT COULD
CHANGE THE WORLD.
DR. OHNEISER: AH!
DR. BEJDER: WE'RE IN
SOME PRETTY THICK ICE HERE.
FRED: I CAN'T
SEE (BLEEP) ANYMORE.
CAPTAIN WALKER: HEY,
WHAT JUST HAPPENED?
SOMETHING, I
JUST HIT SOMETHING.
[ALARM].
MAN: WE'VE GOT AN ALARM.
SEND SOMEBODY
TO INVESTIGATE IT.
MAN: WANT TO PUT THE
PROPULSION MOTOR IN NEUTRAL?
SEAN: THAT
LOOKS (BLEEP) STEEP.
BLOODY HELL.
[INAUDIBLE].
NARRATOR: ANTARCTICA IS THE
LAST GREAT MYSTERY ON EARTH.
♪ ♪
IN THIS FROZEN WASTELAND,
AT THE BOTTOM OF THE PLANET,
IT TAKES A MASSIVE
EFFORT JUST TO SURVIVE.
THERE ARE OVER 70 BASES.
BUILT BY 30 COUNTRIES.
AND SPREAD
ACROSS THE CONTINENT.
AT THE MOUTH
OF MCMURDO SOUND,
IN THE HEART OF
THE ROSS SEA REGION,
IS SCOTT BASE, NEW ZEALAND'S
PERMANENT RESEARCH OUTPOST.
TRUDIE: HEY GUYS,
WELCOME TO SCOTT BASE.
PETER MCCARTHY:
GET YOUR GEAR OFF.
GET COMFORTABLE.
NARRATOR: HERE
SCIENTISTS ARE HOUSED, FED,
AND PROTECTED FROM THE
ELEMENTS BY A NETWORK OF
GREEN BUILDINGS, LINKED
BY WEATHERPROOF TUNNELS,
AND IT'S ALL COORDINATED
BY SCOTT BASE LEADERSHIP.
PETER MCCARTHY: RIGHT
NOW AT SCOTT BASE THIS IS
THE BUSY SEASON.
IT STARTS IN OCTOBER
AND GOES RIGHT ALL THE
WAY THROUGH TO FEBRUARY.
SO, THAT'S FIVE MONTHS
WE'RE PRETTY MUCH PEAKING.
IN TOTAL WITH HAVE
ABOUT 330 PEOPLE GOING SOUTH.
SO IT'S PRETTY CRAZY.
IT TAKES, YOU KNOW,
OVER 200 PEOPLE TO SUPPORT,
YOU KNOW, 90 SCIENTISTS.
ROB TEASDALE: GET
THAT ONE OVER UP ON TOP.
DR. OHNEISER: I CAN HELP
YOU TIE THAT STUFF DOWN.
NARRATOR: TODAY, THE ROSS
ICE SHELF TEAM IS LEAVING
ON ONE OF THE MOST
AMBITIOUS EXPEDITIONS IN
THE HISTORY OF SCOTT BASE.
CHRISTINA:
WE'RE PACKING UP.
ALL OF OUR SCIENCE
CARGO IS READY TO GO.
NARRATOR: TEN SCIENTISTS,
AND TWO SURVIVAL EXPERTS,
ARE GOING 220 MILES SOUTH TO
A FLOATING MASS OF ICE ATTACHED
TO THE CONTINENT, WHERE NO
ONE HAS LIKELY EVER SET FOOT.
DR. OHNEISER: THE ROSS ICE
SHELF IS THE LARGEST LUMP OF
FLOATING ICE IN THE WORLD.
IT'S THE SIZE OF FRANCE
AND ACTUALLY WE'VE GOT ONE
MEASUREMENT THAT'S
EVER BEEN MADE IN THE 1970'S.
THAT'S IT, AND THE
REST OF IT'S A MYSTERY.
SO LITTLE IS KNOWN.
THE SURFACE OF PLUTO HAS
MUCH BETTER IMAGERY THAN
WHAT'S BENEATH
THE ROSS ICE SHELF.
IT'S A LOT OF NEW STUFF
THAT WE'RE GONNA DISCOVER.
NARRATOR: DR. CHRISTIAN
OHNEISER AND HIS TEAM ARE
HOPING TO LEARN HOW THE
ICE SHELF REACTED TO CLIMATE
SHIFTS IN THE DISTANT PAST,
SO THEY CAN TRY TO PREDICT HOW
FAST IT MIGHT MELT AS THE
CLIMATE CHANGES IN THE FUTURE.
DR. OHNEISER: THE ROSS
ICE SHELF HOLDS BACK A PIECE
OF ICE SHEET
THAT'S THREATENED.
IF IT FALLS
APART AND IT MELTS.
EVEN THOUGH IT'S FAR AWAY,
THE IMPACT WOULD BE SOMEWHERE
IN THE ORDER OF SIX,
SEVEN METERS OF SEA LEVEL.
BUT, I'D BE WORRIED ABOUT
10 CENTIMETERS THAT'S ALREADY
ENOUGH TO IMPACT
LOW-LYING AREAS LIKE WHERE
I COME FROM SOUTH DUNEDIN.
YOU CAN WRITE OFF
WHOLE NEIGHBORHOODS THERE.
SIX METERS OF COURSE
YOU'RE WIPING OUT EVERYTHING.
TOM ARNOLD: WE'VE GOT FIRE
EXTINGUISHERS IN ALL VEHICLES.
ROB TEASDALE: I'LL JUST
GO AND DOUBLE CHECK THAT
THEY'RE IN THERE.
NARRATOR: TOM IS
IN CHARGE TEAM SAFETY,
AND HE HAS TO LEAD THEM
SOUTH ACROSS OVER 200 MILES
OF ROUGH ICE, INCLUDING
A KNOWN AREA OF DEADLY CRACKS
CALLED THE SHEAR ZONE.
TOM ARNOLD: THE SHEAR ZONE,
MASSIVE CREVASSING OUT THERE.
THEY ARE HUGE.
PRETTY HUMBLING SIGHT.
NOBODY IS TO LEAVE A
VEHICLE DURING THAT TIME WE
GO THROUGH THAT AREA.
SOME OF THE CREVASSES
IN THE SHEAR ZONE CAN BE
FIVE, SIX, SEVEN METERS WIDE
AND PROBABLY 30, 40 METERS DEEP.
SO IT REALLY GIVES YOU THAT
PERSPECTIVE THAT WE'RE QUITE A
SMALL FISH IN THE
GRAND SCHEME OF THINGS AND
MOTHER NATURE
REALLY HAS CONTROL HERE.
THREE IN THE BACK,
ONE IN THE FRONT!
YOU'RE GOOD TO GO.
KNOWING THAT IT'S MY
RESPONSIBILITY TO MAKE SURE
THAT EVERYBODY CAN GET
BACK TO SCOTT BASE SAFELY
IS A HUGE, HUGE DEAL.
ROB TEASDALE: LET'S ROLL.
NARRATOR: TO
SURVIVE THE JOURNEY,
THE TEAM IS RELYING
ON SPECIALIZED VEHICLES,
CALLED HÄGGLUNDS.
GREG: THESE HÄGGLUNDS,
PRETTY TOUGH.
THEY'RE TRACK VEHICLES.
THEY SHARE
SIMILARITIES WITH TANKS.
THEY'RE REALLY WELL SUITED
FOR WHAT WE NEED THEM TO DO.
DR. OHNEISER: I'M LOOKING AT
THIS WHITE EXPANSE OF NOTHING,
AND IT'S A BIT CREEPY.
WE'VE SPENT SO
MUCH ENERGY AND TIME.
MONTHS OF PLANNING AND
BUILDING A PIECE OF EQUIPMENT.
BUT, NOW WHAT HAPPENS?
NO ONE'S EVER
DONE THIS BEFORE.
IT'S EXPLORATION.
IT'S GONNA
BE INTERESTING.
FROM THIS POINT ON WE'VE GOT
FOUR HOURS BEFORE WE GET INTO
THE SHEAR ZONE, AND THEN VERY
GINGERLY MAKE OUR WAY THROUGH,
UM, WHAT'S ESSENTIALLY
A MINEFIELD OF CREVASSES.
BARBARA: ANTARCTICA,
WE'RE HERE, WE HAVE ARRIVED.
NARRATOR: SCOTT BASE CAN
ONLY HOUSE 85 PEOPLE AT A TIME.
SO, PROJECTS ARE
CONSTANTLY CYCLING THROUGH.
THERE ARE MORE THAN 90
MISSIONS SCHEDULED THIS SEASON.
NONE OF THEM MORE
CHALLENGING THAN THIS ONE.
DANNY UHLMANN: HEY, GRAHAM.
DR. HILL: DANNY!
DANNY UHLMANN: DO WE
HAVE EVERYTHING WE NEED?
ALL THE CABLES
AND COILS AND SKIS?
DR. HILL:
THEY'RE ALL OUT THERE.
DANNY UHLMANN: GOOD.
NARRATOR: THE MT. EREBUS
TEAM IS STUDYING ANTARCTICA'S
MOST ACTIVE VOLCANO,
CHOPPERING TO 132
DIFFERENT SITES TO PLANT
INSTRUMENTS THAT'LL
CREATE A COMPOSITE IMAGE OF
ITS INNER WORKINGS.
DR. HILL: OOO,
THOSE ARE STINKY.
NARRATOR: TODAY,
THEY'RE GEARING UP TO FLY
NEAR ITS SUMMIT.
DANNY UHLMANN: GETTING
DRESSED TO GO ABOUT 11,000 FEET.
SO, IT COULD BE MINUS 20 UP
THERE AND IT'S A RULE THAT WE
ALWAYS HAVE TO WEAR
THIS BIG PUFFY JACKET IN
THE HELICOPTER
IN CASE IT CRASHES.
DR. HILL: ANOTHER DAY.
DOUBLE LAYERS FOR
COMFORT AND EXTRA WARMTH.
NARRATOR: DR. GRAHAM
HILL IS A LEAD SCIENTIST
FOR THE PROJECT.
DR. HILL: WE'RE MEASURING
THE ELECTRIC FIELD AND THE
MAGNETIC FIELD OF THE
VOLCANO AT A SERIES OF POINTS,
WHICH WE THEN COMBINE
AND DO EFFECTIVELY A
CAT SCAN OF THE SUBSURFACE.
SO, IF WE CAN GET A
COULD GET A GOOD UNDERSTANDING
OF WHAT THE STRUCTURE IS,
WE HAVE A BETTER UNDERSTANDING
OF WHAT SIGNALS
THEY MIGHT GENERATE WHEN
THEY'RE GOING TO ERUPT.
WE'LL BE HEADING OUT.
DR. HILL: AND WE CAN
APPLY WHAT WE LEARN ABOUT HOW
THIS VOLCANO WORKS TO
OTHER VOLCANOES ELSEWHERE
IN THE WORLD.
BECAUSE QUITE A LOT OF PEOPLE
LIVE NEAR VOLCANIC CENTERS.
SO, IF THEY ERUPT,
THAT COULD JUST WIPE OUT
THE SURROUNDING AREA.
VOLCANOES HAVE A BIG
IMPACT ON HUMAN LIFE.
DANNY UHLMANN:
LET'S GET OVER THERE.
DR. HILL:
TIME TO GO TO WORK.
DANNY UHLMANN:
ANOTHER DAY IN PARADISE.
NARRATOR: DANNY
ISN'T A SCIENTIST.
HE'S A WORLD
CLASS MOUNTAINEER.
AND IT'S HIS JOB IS
TO KEEP THE TEAM ALIVE ON
THE SIDE OF THE VOLCANO.
DANNY UHLMANN: LET'S GO.
I LOVE DOING MY JOB.
I GET TO TAKE PEOPLE ON
ALL THESE FANTASTIC ADVENTURES,
BUT YOU'RE NOT IN
CONTROL OF THE ENVIRONMENT.
EITHER YOU'RE
SAFE AND YOU COME HOME,
OR YOU SCREW UP
AND YOU DON'T COME HOME.
RADIO: INDIA DELTA
ECHO MAC CENTER, ROGER.
NARRATOR: THIS IS HEFF.
HEFF FLIES THE CHOPPER.
MT. EREBUS IS JUST
MORE THAN 20 MILES AWAY AND
HE HAS TO NAVIGATE
UNPREDICTABLE WINDS.
HEFF: BIT OF
A BREEZE UP HERE.
20 KNOTS MAYBE.
DANNY UHLMANN: PRETTY GOOD.
NARRATOR: HE ALSO HAS TO
FIND A SAFE PLACE TO LAND.
AND THE WHOLE MOUNTAIN
IS COVERED IN CREVASSES.
DANNY UHLMANN: BASICALLY,
A CREVASSE IS LIKE AN OPENING
IN THE GLACIER LIKE THIS.
THERE'S A LOT OF
ACTION IN THIS AREA,
A LOT OF
MOVEMENT IN THE GLACIER.
HEFF: OH, LOOK AT THAT.
DANNY UHLMANN: WOW.
HEFF: THAT IS ONE
MOTHER OF A BLOODY CREVASSE.
DANNY UHLMANN: SOMETIMES
YOU CAN SEE RIGHT INTO THEM
AND YOU GO, "YUP,
THAT'S A CREVASSE.
I'M NOT GOING TO LAND
IN THAT BIG, GAPING HOLE."
BUT OFTEN, IT CAN BE HIDDEN
UNDERNEATH A SNOW BRIDGE.
FROM THE HELICOPTER THEY COULD
BE ANY OLD SIZE, YOU KNOW?
DR. HILL: YEAH,
SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
SOME PEOPLE WOULD THINK THAT
WE'RE A LITTLE BIT CRAZY TO
COME TO ANTARCTICA AND FLY
AROUND ON A CREVASSE-FILLED
VOLCANO THAT IS ERUPTING.
YOU CAN SEE WE'RE KINDA
OUT IN THE MIDDLE OF THAT
ICE STREAM THERE.
HEFF: YEAH.
DR. HILL: WHEN YOU TELL
PEOPLE THESE KIND OF THINGS
BACK HOME THEY DO
LOOK AT YOU A BIT ODD.
"WHY WOULD YOU DO THAT?"
IT'S JUST ONE OF THE REALITIES
OF ACTUALLY DOING THE WORK.
HEFF: ALL RIGHT, ONE MILE.
START LOOKIN.
DANNY UHLMANN: WE'LL JUST
FIND THE NICEST LOOKING SPOT.
HEFF: RIGHT IN FRONT OF US.
DR. HILL: THAT'S GREAT HEFF.
BUT WE'RE WORKING
WITH EXCELLENT PILOTS,
SOME OF THE
BEST IN THE WORLD.
WE'VE GOT TOTAL FAITH IN
THE GUYS WE'RE FLYING WITH.
HEFF: ALL RIGHT, LET'S GET
DOWN TO THE, UM, BUSINESS END.
RIGHT-O, I'M JUST
GONNA COME IN THERE.
GRAVITY'S TAKING HOLD.
NARRATOR: THEY'VE LANDED,
BUT THEY'RE NOT
OUT OF THE WOODS YET.
JUST THIS YEAR, A VETERAN
PILOT FROM AN AUSSIE BASE
LANDED ON WHAT
APPEARED TO BE SAFE GROUND.
NEWS ANCHOR: HE WAS
DELIVERING FUEL TO A DEPOT
ON THE WEST ICE SHELF.
AFTER GETTING OUT
OF HIS HELICOPTER,
HE FELL INTO
A DEEP CREVASSE.
THEY MANAGED TO RETRIEVE
HIM FROM A DEPTH OF ABOUT
20 METERS, BUT HE
DIED OF HIS INJURIES.
[HELICOPTER BLADES SPINNING].
NARRATOR: IT'S DANNY'S
JOB TO CHECK FOR CREVASSES,
LIKE THAT ONE WHILE THE
PILOT KEEPS THE ROTOR SPINNING
TO TAKE OFF QUICKLY
IF THE SNOW CAVES IN.
HEFF: ALRIGHT, I
WOULD SAY JUMP OUT THERE.
[HELICOPTER BLADES SPINNING].
DANNY UHLMANN: ARE THE
PROBES IN THE POD THERE?
HEFF: IT'S IN YOUR POD, YEP.
DANNY UHLMANN: OKAY.
NARRATOR: THE
MT. EREBUS TEAM'S
CHOPPER IS STILL POWERED,
SO IT CAN LIFT OFF IF A
CREVASSE OPENS UP BENEATH THEM.
DANNY UHLMANN: I'LL
JUST GO HAVE A LITTLE POKE.
NARRATOR: AND ITS DANNY'S JOB
TO TEST FOR HARD-PACKED SNOW,
AND AVOID HIDDEN HOLES.
DANNY UHLMANN: THERE'S NO
DOUBT IN MY MIND THAT WE'RE ON
TERRAIN THAT HAS CREVASSES
UNDERNEATH THAT WE CAN'T SEE.
IT IS A PRETTY
HEAVY RESPONSIBILITY;
I'VE HAD VERY CLOSE
FRIENDS DIE IN CREVASSE FALLS
IN SITUATIONS JUST LIKE
WHAT WE'RE DEALING WITH HERE.
SO, FOR ME, IT'S
SOMETHING THAT'S VERY REAL.
OKAY.
NARRATOR: HE'S WEARING
SKIS TO SPREAD OUT HIS WEIGHT,
BUT EVEN SO, EVERY
STEP IS TREACHEROUS.
IT'S KIND OF LIKE THIS...
WALKING BETWEEN
TWO SKYSCRAPERS,
AT LEAST THE
WALKER CAN SEE THE DROP,
SEE THE WIRE STRAIGHT AHEAD.
CRAZY AS IT MIGHT BE, IF
HE PUTS ONE FOOT IN FRONT
OF THE OTHER, HE'LL
MAKE IT SAFELY ACROSS,
AND AVOID A 1300-FOOT DROP.
DANNY COULD BE
OVER A SIMILAR DROP AND
HE CAN'T EVEN SEE THE WIRE.
DANNY UHLMANN: I'M JUST
GONNA POKE AROUND A BIT.
I HAVE TO POKE
AROUND AND REALLY HAVE A
GOOD INSPECTION OF THE SITE.
KINDA FEELING THE
SNOW FOR THE CONSISTENCY,
AND THE SNOW DEPTH.
♪ ♪
HEFF: AH-HAA, WE MADE IT!
DANNY UHLMANN: OPEN THIS.
HEY, GUYS.
I THINK IT LOOKS
GOOD TO GET OUT.
IT'S A NICE ACCUMULATION ZONE
SO THERE'S LOTS OF SNOW HERE
AND IT'S A NICE
COMPRESSION AREA AS WELL.
SO, I THINK, AS LONG
WE KEEP IT NICE AND TIGHT,
WE SHOULD BE FINE.
YOU JUST HAVE TO HAVE
A LITTLE BIT OF FAITH.
NOW, I KINDA
BLESS THE AREA.
THIS AREA IS SAFE AND PEOPLE
CAN GET OUT AND START WORKING.
NARRATOR: GRAHAM AND
HIS TEAM ARE ON THE CLOCK.
THEY HAVE TO
BURY FOUR SENSORS IN
FOUR DIFFERENT DIRECTIONS,
AND RUN HUNDREDS OF FEET
OF CABLE BACK TO A CENTRAL
COMPUTER AND THE CHOPPER
WILL BE BACK FOR THEM
IN TWO HOURS.
DR. HILL: FINGERS ARE
GETTING A BIT CHILLY TRYING
TO DO THIS
HERE IN THE WIND.
MICHAL: BUT I THINK I
HAVE DRANK TOO MUCH WATER.
DANNY UHLMANN: WOW MAN, IT
LOOKS LIKE YOU WERE HYDRATED.
GOOD JOB.
NARRATOR: IN ANTARCTICA,
NOTHING GETS LEFT BEHIND:
NOT EVEN URINE.
IN AN EFFORT TO PRESERVE
THE MOST PRISTINE ENVIRONMENT
ON THE PLANET, ALL HUMAN WASTE
IS BROUGHT BACK TO SCOTT BASE.
[TOILET FLUSH].
AND EVERY BIT
OF IT ENDS UP HERE.
PAUL BOWERING:
AFTER THIS COMES OUT,
YOU KNOW A WOMAN WILL NEVER
LOOK AT ME AGAIN, DON'T YOU?
NARRATOR: PAUL IS IN CHARGE
OF THE WATER TREATMENT CENTER,
BETTER KNOWN AS THE POO PLANT.
PAUL BOWERING: BECAUSE THERE'S
SO MUCH INFLUENT AT THE MOMENT.
IT'S KIND OF EASIER
ON THE SYSTEM JUST TO DO
SOME MANUAL STUFF.
OUR INFLUENT COMES IN
THROUGH THE MAIN SEWER PIPE
AND THROUGH
THE BRUSH SCREEN.
THE BRUSH SCREEN
TAKES OUT SOLID STUFF AND
THAT GOES INTO A BAG.
SO, THIS IS WHAT
WE END UP WITH OUT
OF THE SLUDGE PROCESS.
IT'S ALMOST LIKE BEEF
JERKY LOOKING THING.
WOULDN'T SELL IT
IN YOUR LOCAL STORE,
BUT THAT'S A
LOT OF BEEF JERKY.
NARRATOR: THE WASTE BECOMES
SCOTT BASE'S PRIMARY EXPORT.
PAUL BOWERING:
THERE'S ONE, GOOD TO GO.
NARRATOR: EVERYTHING
THAT CAN'T BE RECYCLED IS
SENT BACK TO NEW ZEALAND.
IT'S PART OF A GLOBAL
EFFORT TO MINIMIZE IMPACT ON
THE FROZEN CONTINENT,
A GOAL OF A TREATY SIGNED
BY 53 NATIONS.
PAUL BOWERING: YOU CAN'T JUST
HAVE THE WASTE FROM PEOPLE AND
EVERYTHING HAPPENING HERE JUST
DISAPPEARING INTO THE OCEAN.
IT'S, UH, IT'S
GOTTA BE TREATED.
IT'S GOTTA, WE
GOTTA LOOK AFTER.
NARRATOR: JUST LIKE
THE CONTINENT ITSELF,
THE SURROUNDING OCEAN
IS CAREFULLY PROTECTED.
WILDLIFE MIGRATES TO
THESE WATERS EVERY YEAR,
AND PERHAPS NO FEEDING
GROUND IS MORE IMPORTANT THAN
ONE OFF THE COAST
OF THE ANTARCTIC PENINSULA.
THE NORTHERNMOST
TIP OF THE MAINLAND.
TED: DO YOU SEE ANY PARTICULAR
SITES OF CONCENTRATION?
DR. FRIEDLAENDER: BACK
IN HERE, IF IT'S CALM,
THIS IS WHERE THOSE
ANIMALS WILL BE SLEEPING.
TED: OH NICE.
NARRATOR: DR. ARI
FRIEDLAENDER IS ONE OF THE
PREEMINENT SCIENTISTS AND
CONSERVATIONISTS IN HIS FIELD.
DR. FRIEDLAENDER: SO
THERE'S SOMETHING SPECIAL ABOUT
THE THREE OR FOUR
AREAS RIGHT IN HERE,
THAT THERE'S ALWAYS WHALES.
NARRATOR: HIS GOAL IS TO STUDY
HUMPBACK AND MINKE WHALES,
TO FIND OUT HOW THEIR
ECOSYSTEM RESPONDS TO A
CHANGING CLIMATE.
DR. FRIEDLAENDER: THIS IS
SORT OF RIGHT IN THE MIDDLE
OF THAT FEEDING SEASON.
SO, FILL IN THAT GAP OF
WHAT THESE ANIMALS ARE DOING
AT THIS TIME OF YEAR
IS GONNA BE PRETTY AWESOME.
WE'RE TRYING TO MEASURE
THE UNDERWATER BEHAVIOR AND
MOVEMENTS OF THE WHALES,
GET AN ESTIMATE OF THEIR SIZE,
AND WE'RE TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT WHALES NEED
TO SURVIVE AND THE
AMOUNT OF FOOD THAT THEY EAT.
IF YOU DON'T EAT ENOUGH,
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO REPRODUCE,
AND IF YOU DON'T REPRODUCE,
IT'S A VERY QUICK PROCESS INTO
YOUR POPULATION NOT GROWING.
TED: WE JUST LEFT
DECEPTION ISLAND.
WE'LL EASILY GET INTO
THE GERLACHE STRAITS,
IN THE MOUTH OF THE
HARARAH CHANNEL BY DAWN.
DR. FRIEDLAENDER: PERFECT.
TED: IF THE WHALES ARE LOOKING
GOOD, YOU CAN BE OUT WORKING.
DR. FRIEDLAENDER: COOL.
THIS IS A PLACE WHERE
PEOPLE HAVE MADE HUGE CHANGES
IN THE ENVIRONMENT.
OVER THE LAST 50 YEARS,
THE WINTER AIR HAS RAISED
BY ABOUT
FIVE DEGREES CELSIUS.
THE SEA ICE OVER
THE LAST 30 YEARS,
ON THIS PART OF THE PENINSULA,
HAS DECREASED IN THE NUMBER OF
DAYS THAT ARE ICE COVERED.
THERE'S A HUGE STANDING
STOCK OF KRILL HERE,
AND THAT'S WHAT
THEY NEED TO FEED ON.
BUT THE WARMING
THAT'S OCCURRED HERE,
IF THAT AFFECTS THE WAY
THE KRILL ARE DISTRIBUTED,
IT COULD MEAN SOMETHING
PRETTY SIGNIFICANT.
NARRATOR: MORE THAN 4
BILLION PEOPLE RELY ON SEAFOOD
AS A STAPLE.
AND THE FISH WE EAT,
EAT SMALLER FISH,
WHICH EAT SMALLER
FISH, IN SOME CASES,
ALL THE WAY DOWN THE
CHAIN TO THIS: KRILL.
AS SEA ICE RECEDES, THE
ALGAE THEY EAT GOES WITH IT.
AND IF KRILL DISAPPEARS,
SO DOES THE
WHALE'S FOOD SUPPLY,
AND A BIG PART OF OUR OWN.
DR. FRIEDLAENDER: WE'VE GOT THE
DRONES AND THE SUCTION CUP TAGS.
DR. BEJDER: SEE IF
THEY SURVIVED THE TRIP.
DR. FRIEDLAENDER:
WE HAVE A SMALL UAV,
A LITTLE QUADCOPTER
WITH A CAMERA ON IT.
WHEN WE FLY
THAT OVER THE WHALE,
WE CAN GET A VERY
PRECISE ESTIMATE OF THE
SIZE OF THAT ANIMAL.
DR. BEJDER: SO WE'RE
JUST GOING TO FIRE THE
MOTORS UP WITHOUT THE PROPS.
MAKE SURE
THAT'S ALL RUNNING.
DR. FRIEDLAENDER: THE
OTHER THING THAT WE DO IS
DEPLOYING SUCTION CUP TAGS.
THESE TAGS ARE
BASICALLY LIKE A SMARTPHONE.
THEY RECORD THE
ANGLE OF THE WHALE,
WHETHER IT'S ROLLED
OVER ON ITS SIDE,
THE HEADING OF THE
WHALE, THE DEPTH,
AND THE SPEED OF
THE WHALE AND IT DOES
THAT HUNDREDS
OF TIMES A SECOND.
IT ALSO RECORDS VIDEO, WHICH
IS AWESOME BECAUSE WE CAN THEN,
SORT OF, CORROBORATE THE
THINGS THAT THE SENSORS ARE
TELLING US WITH WHAT WE
ACTUALLY SEE THE WHALE DOING.
IT'S GOT TWO
720P CAMERAS IN THERE.
WE CAN GET ABOUT NINE
HOURS OF CONTINUOUS DATA.
AND ALL OF THAT
PACKAGED TOGETHER GIVES US
A REALLY PRECISE, UH,
ESTIMATE OF THE HEALTH OF
THE ANIMALS DOWN HERE.
DR. BEJDER: TAGS, DATA,
UAV DATA COMBINED IS GOING
TO BE OPENING
NEW WORLDS REALLY.
SO, LET'S GO
FIND SOME WHALES!
DR. FRIEDLAENDER:
YEAH, LET'S DO IT!
♪ ♪
ROB TEASDALE: OKAY TEAM,
THIS MARKS THE SHEAR ZONE.
SO, COME IN NICE
AND CLOSE BEHIND US.
DR. OHNEISER:
OKAY, THANK YOU.
NARRATOR: THE ROSS ICE
SHELF TEAM HAS TRAVELED ABOUT
30 MILES, AND THEY'RE
FACING THE MOST DANGEROUS
PART OF THEIR TRAVERSE.
TOM ARNOLD: OH, WE'RE
JUST ABOUT TO ENTER INTO
THE SHEAR ZONE HERE.
WE JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT EVERYBODY'S CAPABLE,
SHOULD THE WORST
POSSIBLE CASE HAPPEN.
NARRATOR: THE SHEAR
ZONE LOOKS LIKE A SAFE
PATCH OF SNOW, BUT
LIKE MT. EREBUS IT'S FULL
OF HIDDEN CREVASSES.
ROB TEASDALE: FIRST FLAT
NOT AS BENIGN AS IT LOOKS.
THERE'S A LOT GOING ON.
ON ONE SIDE, WE'VE GOT SORT
OF THE MCMURDO, UM, ICE SHELF.
AND THE OTHER IS
THE ROSS ICE SHELF.
IT'S WHERE TWO LARGE,
KIND OF ICE MASSES ARE COMING
TOGETHER, MUCH LIKE
A RIVER COMES TOGETHER.
AND THE REASON IT'S CALLED
A SHEAR ZONE IS BECAUSE
THERE'S KIND OF A SHEARING
EFFECT BETWEEN THE TWO.
SO IT'S QUITE
AN ACTIVE AREA.
INTERESTING SPOT.
TOM ARNOLD: THE SHEAR
ZONE IS AN INTIMIDATING AREA:
AROUND ABOUT SIX OR SO
KILOMETERS THAT HAVE A NUMBER
OF SIGNIFICANTLY
LARGE CREVASSES IN THEM.
WE KNOW THAT THERE'S
A ROUTE THROUGH THERE.
WE REALLY REDUCE THAT
SPEED DOWN EVEN FURTHER SO THAT
WE'RE A 100% SURE OF
WHAT WE'RE DRIVING ON IS
GOOD TO DRIVE ACROSS.
ROB TEASDALE: JUST KEEP A
LITTLE EXTRA FOLLOWING DISTANCE.
DR. OHNEISER: HOW FAR DO
YOU WANT, 50 METERS, 100?
ROB TEASDALE: UH,
MAYBE 50 METERS.
WE'RE JUST GONNA
BE GOING A LITTLE BIT SLOWER
THROUGH HERE, AND IF
WE STOP, YOU SHOULD TOO.
TOM ARNOLD: WE'RE JUST
GONNA GET ALL OUR GEAR PREPARED
FOR A CREVASSE RESCUE.
ROB TEASDALE: PROCEED
WITH CAUTION, FINGERS CROSSED.
NARRATOR: CROSSING THE SHEAR
ZONE SHOULD TAKE A FEW HOURS.
BUT TOM AND ROB HAVE BEEN
PREPARING FOR IT FOR WEEKS.
ROB TEASDALE: SO, THIS IS
THE RADAR BOOM FOR OUR PB 100.
WE WILL BE FITTING A GPR UNIT,
GROUND PENETRATING RADAR,
AND WE'LL BE ABLE TO SEE
ON THE MONITOR WHEN WE'RE
APPROACHING CREVASSES
AND THAT'LL ENABLE US
TO NOT DRIVE INTO THEM.
STATE OF THE ART TECHNOLOGY.
REAL KEY PIECE OF THIS
WHOLE PROJECT FOR THIS YEAR
AND GOING INTO
THE FUTURE AS WELL.
SO, JUST GOTTA
GET IT UP AND RUNNING.
NARRATOR: THE BOOM
STRETCHES 24 FEET AHEAD,
AND CONNECTS TO A SCREEN
THAT SHOWS ICE COMPOSITION
UP TO 49 FEET DEEP.
BENDS IN THE LINES INDICATE
EMPTY SPACE UNDER THE SNOW.
TOM ARNOLD: SOME OF THE
CREVASSES THROUGH HERE WOULD
LITERALLY SWALLOW THIS
WHOLE VEHICLE, AND PROBABLY THE,
UH, TWO TRAILERS BEHIND IT.
UM, SO, IF WE HADN'T
LOOKED AT THE RADAR IMAGERY,
AND WE ACTUALLY JUST CARRIED
ON, DROPPED INTO A CREVASSE,
IT WOULD PROBABLY BE ALL OVER.
ROB TEASDALE: OKAY TEAM,
WE'RE JUST GOING TO HEAD OFF
SLOWLY AIMING FOR
ABOUT 12K AN HOUR.
DR. OHNEISER: ROGER FROM H1.
ANDREW: ROGER ON THAT FROM H2.
ROB TEASDALE: WE
GOT SOME UM BLACK FLAGS
COMING UP HERE, TOM.
SHOULD BE SEEING SOMETHING
FAIRLY SHORTLY I'D SAY.
DR. OHNEISER: IT'S
KINDA CREEPY, YA KNOW?
SO, EACH ONE OF THESE
WOODEN STAKES HERE REPRESENTS
A KNOWN CREVASSE.
RIGHT NOW, WE'VE GOT
ONE FIVE METERS THAT WAY
AND ONE SIX
METERS THAT WAY.
LAURINE VAN HAASTREECHT: YEAH,
THOSE BLACK FLAGS ARE A LITTLE
BIT FREAKY WHEN YOU SEE
THEM RIGHT BY WHERE YOU ARE.
JUST ALONG THE WHOLE ROAD
AND THE CREVASSE AREA YOU SEE
BLACK FLAGS EVERYWHERE.
BLACK FLAGS MEAN, WELL,
"DEATH" OR DON'T GO THERE SO
THAT'S A BIT NERVE-WRACKING.
DR. OHNEISER: IT IS A BIT
SPOOKY, YEAH, WHEN YOU KNOW,
YOU KNOW YOU'RE WALKING
THROUGH THE ALLIGATOR PIT.
TOM ARNOLD: YEAH, WE
BELIEVE THIS TO BE PROBABLY
THE MOST DANGEROUS AREA.
ROB TEASDALE: HEY GUYS,
WE'RE ABOUT HALFWAY THROUGH.
UMM, YOU CAN SEE HOW
THIS FLAG LINE'S KINDA
NO LONGER STRAIGHT, SORT
OF INDICATIVE OF HOW MUCH
THIS ROAD'S MOVING.
DR. OHNEISER:
YEAH, ROGER THAT.
THAT'S CRAZY, WOW.
THERE'S SO MANY
CREVASSES HERE.
WE DON'T WANT TO HAVE
ANY DEATHS BEFORE WE EVEN
GET THE SCIENCE DONE.
NARRATOR: THE LARGEST
CREVASSES EVER MEASURED ON THE
ROSS ICE SHELF ARE
ALMOST 350 FEET ACROSS AND
500 FEET DEEP.
AND SINCE THE WHOLE
ICE SHELF IS FLOATING,
THE CRACKS IN IT
ARE CONSTANTLY MOVING.
ROB TEASDALE: COUPLE
MORE BLACK FLAGS COMING UP.
THEY LOOK LIKE
REASONABLY NEW BLACK FLAGS.
TOM ARNOLD: THERE'S
SOMETHING COMING IN NOW
PRETTY HIGH ACTUALLY.
THE BOOM IS ABOUT 7.5 METERS
LONG AND IT GIVES US AROUND
ABOUT 3 TO 6 SECONDS
OF STOPPING DISTANCE ONCE
WE SEE SOMETHING
COME UP ON THE SCREEN.
BIG, BIG VOID GOING DOWN;
SOMETHING TO
BE CONCERNED ABOUT.
STOP THERE, STOP!
DR. OHNEISER: WELL,
HE'S ACTUALLY STOPPED NOW.
ROB TEASDALE: WE JUST
STOPPED OVER A CRACK.
OBVIOUS VOID UNDERNEATH.
TOM ARNOLD: DEEP
VOID UNDERNEATH,
BUT THE SURFACE IS
PRETTY BRIDGED RIGHT ACROSS.
STOP THERE, STOP!
DR. OHNEISER: WELL,
HE'S ACTUALLY STOPPED NOW.
NARRATOR: THE ROSS ICE SHELF
TEAM IS IN THE SHEAR ZONE,
AN AREA LITTERED WITH
DEADLY CRACKS IN THE ICE,
AND THE LEAD VEHICLE
IS RIGHT ON TOP OF ONE.
TOM ARNOLD: WE JUST
STOPPED OVER A CRACK.
OBVIOUS VOID UNDERNEATH.
THREE, FOUR METERS STRETCH.
BRIDGES BASICALLY
HIDING THE CREVASSES,
SO THEY'VE GIVEN YOU A FALSE
IDEA OF WHAT'S BENEATH THERE.
SO, DRIVING ALONG YOU CAN'T
ACTUALLY SEE THAT THERE'S
A CREVASSE DOWN THERE.
[GRUNTS].
ROB, I'LL RUN IT ROUND
YOUR SIDE AND THEN YOU CAN
CLIP ON AS WELL.
JUST MAKING SURE THAT
WE'VE GOT EVERYTHING WE NEED.
HARNESSES ARE
FITTING CORRECTLY,
ALL THE BUCKLES AND LOOPS
ARE DONE UP AS THEY SHOULD BE.
UH, WE'VE WELL AND
TRULY OPENED THIS UP.
THAT'S ALL THAT SNOW BRIDGE
THAT WE WERE TALKING ABOUT.
YOU CAN'T QUITE SEE
THE BOTTOM BUT IT GOES DOWN
AT LEAST 30 METERS.
SO YEAH, I'M JUST GOING
TO PROBE THIS SIDE HERE, ROB,
AND SEE HOW THAT LOOKS
FOR A SLIGHTLY BETTER CROSSING.
ROB TEASDALE: YUP.
TOM ARNOLD: VOIDED,
I'VE GOT THROUGH THERE.
LOOKS GOOD.
YEAH, SO THE CRACK IS
STILL HERE BUT IT'S ONLY MAYBE,
15 OR SO CENTIMETERS WIDE.
SO, IT IS OBVIOUSLY
NARROWING AS WE GO.
YEAH, THAT'S
LOOKING REAL GOOD.
FROM HERE, THROUGH
HERE WOULD BE SWEET.
WE'LL BE ABLE TO BRING
THEM THROUGH THIS WAY.
ROB TEASDALE: LET'S JUST
WATCH THEM COME ACROSS AND
GET THEM TO PARK UP
BEFORE THIS NEXT POST HERE.
TOM ARNOLD: YEAH.
ROB TEASDALE: AND ONCE
THEY STOP, THEN WE'LL GO.
ALRIGHT GUYS, WE'RE JUST
GOING TO HEAD OFF SLOWLY.
YOU CAN SEE THE TWO
LINES THAT TOM MADE OVER
BY THE FLAGS OVER THERE.
THAT'S GOING TO BE WHERE
YOU GUYS ARE GONNA CROSS.
DR. OHNEISER:
ROGER, THANK YOU.
IT IS ACTUALLY QUITE
SCARY DOING THIS.
I'M VERY NERVOUS DRIVING,
YOU CAN FALL
DOWN INTO A DEEP HOLE,
AND YOU
PROBABLY WILL DIE.
IT HAPPENS, IT'S HAPPENED
BEFORE IN ANTARCTICA.
BUT WE CAN'T TURN BACK,
AND WE'VE SPENT
SO MUCH TIME PLANNING.
YOU JUST HAVE TO
GET THROUGH THAT.
I MEAN THAT'S WHAT
TOM AND ROB ARE THERE FOR.
TOM ARNOLD: YOU'RE
GOING TO COME IN A LITTLE
BIT RIGHT NOW, ROB.
ROB TEASDALE: BRING IT OVER
TOWARDS ME A LITTLE BIT, PLEASE.
AND STOP.
TOM ARNOLD: CLEAR!
WOO!
ROB TEASDALE: WE'RE ALIVE!
TOM ARNOLD: WELL DONE.
ROB TEASDALE: WE
SHOULD BE GOOD TO GO.
TOM ARNOLD: LET'S GET SOME
KILOMETERS UNDER THE BELT.
NARRATOR: THE TEAM
IS SAFELY ACROSS.
BUT NOW, SCOTT BASE
COMMS IS MONITORING A STORM
HEADING UP
FROM THE SOUTH POLE.
MAJOR MCCOLL: H4
THIS IS SCOTT BASE.
TOM ARNOLD: SCOTT BASE,
SCOTT BASE, P-B ZERO ONE.
MAJOR MCCOLL: THE WEATHER
IS THE DETERMINING FACTOR HERE
SHOWING AT THE MOMENT
40 KNOTS OF WIND POSSIBLY
GUSTING TO UP TO 55 KNOTS.
BAD CONDITIONS THEIR
VISIBILITY WILL DROP.
SNOW GONNA PASS
THROUGH THE AREA.
QUITE HEAVY SNOW.
TOM ARNOLD: ROGER.
DEFINITELY A RELIEF TO
GET THROUGH THE SHEAR ZONE.
BUT WHERE WE'RE DRIVING TO
IS PRETTY MUCH DIRECTLY SOUTH
WHICH IS WHERE THE STORM
SYSTEM'S GONNA COME IN FROM.
I GUESS YOU'RE ALWAYS
HOPING IT'S NOT GOING TO BE
AS BAD AS IT'S FORECASTED.
IT MIGHT BLOW OUT,
AND WE'LL HAVE FINE, GOOD,
REASONABLY GOOD WEATHER.
BUT, YEARS' WORTH OF
PLANNING GONE INTO THESE EVENTS,
SO GETTING MOVING
AND SEEING HOW IT GOES IS
KIND OF PART OF,
PART OF HOW IT HAS TO
WORK DOWN IN ANTARCTICA.
DR. OHNEISER: ROB AND
TOM HAVE GUIDED US THROUGH.
NOW WE ADVANCE
ONWARD INTO NOTHING.
WOW, IT'S CRAZY.
IT'S JUST ICE
SHELF AND HORIZON NOW.
DANNY UHLMANN:
YEAH, I'M READY MAN.
MICHAL: 3 DEGREES TO THE
LEFT OF THIS LITTLE CLOUD.
DANNY UHLMANN:
OKAY, I'M GOING.
I THINK WE HAVE TO BE A
LITTLE BIT MORE MINIMAL
WITH THE STOPPING, OR ELSE
WE'RE GONNA GET IN TROUBLE.
DR. HILL: START DIGGING!
NARRATOR: THE MT. EREBUS
TEAM BURIES INSTRUMENTS ON
A NORTH-SOUTH AND
EAST-WEST AXIS TO MEASURE
THE NATURALLY OCCURRING
ELECTRIC AND MAGNETIC FIELDS
THAT ARE CONSTANTLY PASSING
THROUGH EARTH'S SURFACE.
DANNY UHLMANN: AM I
GOING IN A STRAIGHT LINE?
THAT'S ALWAYS THE QUESTION.
NARRATOR: THE CURRENTS MOVE
THROUGH DIFFERENT LAYERS OF
THE EARTH AT VARYING SPEEDS,
AND A CENTRAL COMPUTER
RECORDS THOSE DIFFERENCES.
THEIR GOAL IS TO COLLECT DATA
ACROSS 132 DIFFERENT SITES,
AND COMBINE THEM TO
CREATE A PICTURE OF THE
VOLCANO'S INNER
STRUCTURE AND MAGMA FLOW.
DR. HILL: THIS LITTLE
BOX IS THE BRAINS OF THE
OPERATION OUT HERE
AND IS BASICALLY A REALLY,
REALLY FANCY DATA COLLECTOR.
NARRATOR: AND ALL OF
IT HAS TO HAPPEN BEFORE
THE CHOPPER
COMES BACK FOR THEM.
DR. HILL: IT TAKES US
ABOUT AN HOUR AND A HALF
TO PUT ONE INTO THE GROUND.
OR IF IT'S A SITE WHERE IT'S
NOT SNOW THAT YOU'RE TRYING TO
DIG, IT'S GLACIAL ICE;
IT CAN TAKE SIX, SEVEN HOURS.
SO, YOU HAVE TO REALIZE
THINGS ARE GOING TO TAKE LONGER
THAN THEY WOULD PRETTY
MUCH ANYWHERE ELSE IN THE WORLD.
GOT ABOUT AN HOUR OF
SLEEP IN THE LAST 36 HOURS,
BUT THAT'S A GOOD HOLE.
[DIGGING].
DR. FRIEDLAENDER: SO NICK,
LET'S JUST HAVE YOU RIGHT IN
THAT SPOT THERE IS GOOD.
NICK: YEAH, I
FEEL GOOD UP HERE.
DR. FRIEDLAENDER: AND THEN
WE'LL TRY AND DO IT OFF OF
WHICHEVER SIDE, UH,
THE ANIMAL GIVES US.
NARRATOR: ARI IS IN A
SMALL INFLATABLE BOAT,
LOOKING FOR A
66,000-POUND HUMPBACK WHALE.
DR. FRIEDLAENDER: THE
FREQUENCY IS 151.333.
NARRATOR: AND HE HAS TO
GET CLOSE ENOUGH TO ATTACH A
SUCTION MOUNT TO IT WITH
A 23-FOOT METAL POLE.
DR. FRIEDLAENDER: WE'RE
IN WILHELMINA BAY, UH, ONE OF
THE LOCATIONS THAT WE'VE
WORKED IN FOR A LONG TIME,
AND WE'RE GOING TO TRY
AND DEPLOY ONE OF THE VIDEO
RECORDING MULTI-SENSOR
TAGS ON A HUMPBACK.
SO LET'S SEE IF WE CAN SEE
IF THAT WHALE IS STILL THERE.
THE WHALES COME THERE
BECAUSE THE KRILL IS THERE.
WHEN THEY'RE DONE FEEDING,
THEY'LL BASICALLY
TAKE A NAP AT THE SURFACE.
ESSENTIALLY LOOK LIKE A LOG.
FOR US, IT'S A GREAT PLACE
BECAUSE THE WHALES BEHAVE IN A
WAY THAT ALLOWS US TO APPROACH
THEM TO PUT OUR TAGS ON.
I THINK I SEE
SOMETHING OVER THERE.
THERE WE GO, RIGHT
OUT IN FRONT OF US.
OFF OUR BOW.
IF THAT GUY LOOKS LIKE HE
STOPS AND LOGS FOR A WHILE,
WE'LL, UH, GO UP
AND APPROACH HIM.
FIRST APPROACH,
ALWAYS THE BEST.
I'M GOING TO COME EITHER
FROM FIVE OR SEVEN O'CLOCK
AND JUST TRY AND GET THE
TAG ON AS HIGH UP AS POSSIBLE.
IS THAT COOL?
NICK: YUP.
DR. FRIEDLAENDER: ALL RIGHT.
AND JUST STAY,
WHICHEVER WAY WE'RE GOING,
JUST KIND OF STAY
ON THE OPPOSITE SIDE.
IT'S PROBABLY GOING TO BE
ON THE LEFT SIDE OF THE ZODIAC.
WE'RE BASICALLY PREPPED UP.
WE'RE GONNA GO
SNEAK UP ON THIS GUY.
GO REAL SLOW.
THE KEY IS TO NOT
WAKE THEM UP AS WE APPROACH
AND NOT HAVE
THEM RESPOND TO US.
SO, IF WE CAN GET UP TO IT
BY THE TIME IT'S STILL LOGGING,
WE SHOULD BE GOOD.
YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE TO BE
FULL EXTENSION FOR THIS GUY.
NICK: YEP.
DR. FRIEDLAENDER: WHEN WE'RE
APPROACHING THESE WHALES IT'S
DEFINITELY A
HIGH-RISK KINDA SITUATION.
IF ITS FLUKE
HIT THE ZODIAC,
IT WOULD FLIP US
OVER WITHOUT MUCH TROUBLE.
YOU PROBABLY HAVE FIVE OR
SIX MINUTES IN THAT WATER AT THE
MOST BEFORE
HYPOTHERMIA WOULD SET IN AND
IT WOULD BE GAME OVER.
[BOAT ENGINE].
(BLEEP), HE'S GONNA HEAR IT.
NOW IT'S GONNA DIVE, (BLEEP).
IF THE WHALE RESPONDS
TO WHAT YOU'RE DOING,
ITS GENERAL RESPONSE
IS GOING TO BE TO DIVE.
THERE HE GOES.
SOMETIMES WE LOSE TRACK
OF THE WHALE AND WE HAVE
NO WAY OF FINDING IT.
YOU MIGHT SEE A
FOOTPRINT IN THE WATER FROM
WHERE IT KINDA KICKED AWAY,
UH, BUT IT'S LIKE ONE AND DONE.
THIS SUCKS.
DR. FRIEDLAENDER:
I DID SEE A WHALE.
I DON'T SEE A
LOGGING WHALE NOW.
I DON'T KNOW WHERE THE
ONE WAS THAT WENT DOWN HERE.
NARRATOR: ARI AND HIS
TEAM WERE CLOSE TO DEPLOYING
A SUCTION TAG,
BUT THE WHALE THEY WERE
CHASING WENT UNDERWATER.
DR. FRIEDLAENDER: IS THAT
A LOGGING WHALE OUT THERE?
CAN'T TELL.
NO, IT'S NOT.
THESE ANIMALS MOVE OVER
BIG DISTANCES VERY QUICKLY.
THEY'RE A REAL PAIN TO
WORK WITH BECAUSE THEY'RE
DIFFICULT TO FIND.
DO YOU GUYS WANT TO
GET THE DRONE IN THE AIR?
DR. BEJDER: THIS
WOULDN'T BE A BAD SPOT.
DR. FRIEDLAENDER: YEAH.
NARRATOR: ARI'S UAV
SPECIALIST, LARS,
PILOTS A DRONE THAT CAN GIVE
THEM A BIRD'S EYE VIEW TO HELP
FIND A WHALE, AND
GIVE THEM MORE INFORMATION
ABOUT IT WHEN THEY DO.
DR. BEJDER: WE CAN USE
THIS FOOTAGE TO LOOK AT
BODY SIZE OF THESE WHALES.
TYPICALLY, WE USUALLY FLY
THEM IN WARMER CLIMATES.
THIS IS THE FIRST TIME WE'VE
BEEN IN ANTARCTICA FLYING IN
THESE COLDER CONDITIONS.
IS THE MOTOR
WORKING ALRIGHT?
FRED: YEAH, IT
SEEMS TO BE FINE.
DR. BEJDER: GOOD.
HOW'S YOUR FEED
AT THIS DISTANCE?
FRED: IT'S GOOD.
DR. BEJDER: WHAT'S THAT?
FRED: THERE IT IS.
[WHALE NOISE].
DR. BEJDER: OH NICE,
YEAH, THAT'S GOOD.
DR. FRIEDLAENDER:
OH, HE'S GOT A BUDDY,
THAT'S WHY HE'S
KIND OF FIRED UP!
DR. BEJDER: WE'LL TAKE
ONE OF OUR VESSELS WITHIN
THE FRAME WITH THE WHALE.
THAT ALLOWS US TO SCALE THE
SIZE OF THE WHALE TO THE BOAT
AND THAT WILL ALLOW US
TO GET US TO GET AS DIRECT
MEASUREMENTS OF
HOW BIG THE WHALE IS.
[DRONE BUZZ].
NICELY DONE.
DR. FRIEDLAENDER: SWEET.
SO NICK, IT'LL BE NO
DIFFERENT IF THE ANIMAL
IS NOT, UM, LOGGING.
NICK: OKAY.
DR. FRIEDLAENDER: ALRIGHT,
WE'LL APPROACH AS SLOW AS WE
CAN AND STILL BE
MAKING UP SPEED ON IT.
NICK: SURE.
[WHALE NOISE].
DR. FRIEDLAENDER: WHEN
WE'RE APPROACHING A WHALE,
HUMAN SAFETY IS
THE FIRST CONCERN.
THE THING YOU DON'T
WANT TO DO WHEN YOU'RE
APPROACHING THESE
ANIMALS IS STARTLE IT.
ANYWHERE YOU CAN PUT IT
KIND OF IN THE TERRITORY.
NICK: ARE YOU GONNA?
DR. FRIEDLAENDER: I'M GONNA
SWING AROUND, DON'T WORRY.
IT'S GONNA BE
ON OUR PORT SIDE.
NICK: OKAY, SO
WE'LL STILL GOING PORT.
DR. FRIEDLAENDER: IF SOMEONE
ELSE WANTS TO TAKE THE TILLER,
I'LL TAG.
NICK: OKAY.
DR. FRIEDLAENDER: I GOTCHA.
RADIO: HUGH, GO AHEAD.
♪ ♪
DR. FRIEDLAENDER: NICE, SWEET!
CREW: NICE, DUDE.
DR. FRIEDLAENDER: WE'RE HAPPY,
BUT THE WORK IS
DEFINITELY NOT OVER.
THE SUCTION CUP TAGS
ARCHIVE ALL THE DATA ON THEM
SO WE HAVE TO RETRIEVE
THAT TAG TO GET ANYTHING BACK.
[WHALE NOISE].
OH, LOOK, SWEET.
THERE'S THE TAG!
AWESOME.
I THINK THESE ANIMALS HAVE
A LOT MORE GOING ON THAN WE
UNDERSTAND OR THAT
WE HAVE THE ABILITY TO
BE ABLE TO COMPREHEND.
HOLY (BLEEP), MAN.
[CAMERA CLICKING].
THESE ANIMALS GET AS CURIOUS
ABOUT US AS WE DO ABOUT THEM.
IT'S LOOKING AT YOU AND IT'S
KIND OF WONDERING WHAT YOU'RE
DOING THERE AND WE'RE ASKING
THE SAME KIND OF QUESTIONS.
LARS, CORRECT ME IF I'M WRONG.
THIS IS THE FIRST-EVER
FLIGHT IN THE ANTARCTIC, RIGHT?
FOR THIS EQUIPMENT?
DR. BEJDER: YES,
THAT'S CORRECT.
DR. FRIEDLAENDER: COULDN'T
ASK FOR MORE EXCEPT FOR LARS TO
BUY US A COUPLE OF DRINKS.
DR. BEJDER: ONE BIG ONE.
[TEAM LAUGHS].
DR. HILL: OUT HERE,
EVERY MINUTE COUNTS.
WE'VE GOT TO REALLY BE
EFFICIENT TO GET THE JOB DONE.
NARRATOR: THE MT. EREBUS
TEAM HAS INSTALLED
3 OUT OF THEIR 4 SENSORS,
AND RUN WIRING
BACK TO THE MAIN COMPUTER.
DR. HILL: THIS WIND DIRECTION
HAS DEFINITELY CHANGED.
AND THAT CLOUD
IS NOT GOOD, AT ALL.
CAUSE THAT'S COMING UP OFF THE
OPEN WATER ON THE OTHER SIDE.
NARRATOR: BUT THE SAME
STORM THAT'S BEEN THREATENING
THE ROSS ICE SHELF
TEAM IS INCREASING THE
WINDS AT HIGH ALTITUDE.
DR. HILL: HEY, DANNY, HAVE YOU
NOTICED THE CHANGE IN WEATHER?
THAT CLOUD COULD
LEAD TO A CAMPING TRIP.
IF THE WEATHER DESCENDS
ON US WHEN THE HELICOPTER'S
NOT AROUND, YOU
HAVE YOUR SURVIVAL BAGS,
WHICH HAVE TENTS
AND SLEEPING BAGS,
IN CASE YOU DON'T
GET HOME THAT NIGHT.
BUT YOU DON'T
WANT THAT TO HAPPEN.
SCOTT BASE FROM GRAHAM.
RADIO: GO AHEAD.
DR. HILL: YEAH, IF YOU
COULD GET HOLD OF SEAN,
CAN YOU TELL HIM TO RUSH
OUT TO GET US RIGHT NOW?
RADIO: ROGER THAT.
DR. HILL: AH, HOW
YOU DOING, MICHAL?
HEFF: HOW MANY MINUTES
DO YOU THINK YOU'LL BE
UNTIL YOU'RE DONE, GRAHAM.
DR. HILL: UH, WE PROBABLY GOT
ANOTHER SIX OR SEVEN MINUTES.
THERE WE GO.
IT'S WORKING NOW.
HELICOPTER'S GETTING CLOSE.
[HELICOPTER ROTORS].
HEFF: ALRIGHT, WE ALL GOOD?
DR. HILL: WE'RE GOOD.
HEFF: OH YEAH!
TOM ARNOLD: WE'LL JUST
PULL 'ROUND TO THE RIGHT
A COUPLE HUNDRED
METERS AND, UH, SET UP.
ROB TEASDALE: YEAH.
I'LL PULL UP HERE GUYS,
AND YOU CAN COME IN NICE
AND CLOSE BEHIND US.
DR. OHNEISER: ROGER!
NARRATOR: THE ROSS ICE
SHELF TEAM IS NOW 40 MILES
SOUTH OF SCOTT BASE.
AFTER A LONG DAY OF DRIVING,
THEY HAVE NO CHOICE
BUT TO STOP AND REST.
BUT SINCE THEY'RE
THE FURTHEST TEAM SOUTH,
THE WORST OF THE STORM
COULD BE JUST A FEW HOURS AWAY.
TOM ARNOLD: ALRIGHT,
SO THIS IS GOING TO BE OUR
HOME FOR THE NIGHT.
SO, WHAT WE NEED TO
DO IS ESTABLISH A CAMP.
SO, LET'S SAY
THIS IS OUR AREA HERE,
PREVAILING WIND'S
GONNA COME IN FROM HERE.
I LIKE TO HAVE MY CAMP KIND
OF IN A NICE, NEAT LINE, GOING.
THAT MAKES SENSE?
DR. OHNEISER: WE JUST WANT
TO GET EVERYTHING UP AND GET
INSIDE, AND GET OUT OF
THE WIND, 'CAUSE IT'S COLD.
DEFINITELY FEELS
COLDER THAN AT SCOTT BASE.
SCOTT BASE IS GONNA
FEEL TROPICAL COMPARED
TO THIS OUT HERE.
NARRATOR: ONCE
THE STORM HITS,
THESE SCOTT POLAR TENTS
WILL BE THEIR ONLY PROTECTION.
DR. OHNEISER:
HOME SWEET HOME!
NARRATOR: THEY'RE NAMED
AFTER ONE OF THE FIRST MEN
EVER TO
EXPLORE ANTARCTICA,
ROBERT FALCON SCOTT.
THE DESIGN HASN'T CHANGED
MUCH SINCE HE USED THEM,
AND HE WAS IN ONE
JUST LIKE IT RIGHT HERE ON
THE ROSS ICE SHELF.
ACCORDING TO HIS FINAL
MESSAGE: "HAD WE LIVED,"
HE SAID, "I SHOULD HAVE
HAD A TALE TO TELL OF THE
HARDIHOOD, ENDURANCE AND
COURAGE OF MY COMPANIONS,
WHICH WOULD HAVE STIRRED
THE HEART OF EVERY ENGLISHMAN."
THAT MESSAGE
WAS DISCOVERED AFTER HE
AND THOSE
COMPANIONS FROZE TO DEATH.
DR. OHNEISER: IT'S
SUDDENLY QUITE A BIT COLDER.
♪ ♪
DANNY UHLMANN:
MT. EREBUS IS WEARING A NICE
HIGH WIND-SPEED HAT, LOOKS
LIKE A LITTLE NUCLEAR BOMB.
DR. HILL: YUP, IT WAS
ONE OF THOSE DAYS WHERE
BAD WEATHER COMES
IN OUT OF NOWHERE.
AND, HALF HOUR LATER,
GOTTEN REAL FLAT AND REAL DARK.
AND TURN
AROUND AND COME HOME.
I THINK IT LOOKS WORSE
NOW THAN IT DID WHEN WE
WERE IN THE HELICOPTER.
HERE'S THE
OTHER TECHNICAL BAG.
THE NUMBER ONE PRIORITY
IS THAT EVERYBODY'S SAFE AND
EVERYBODY COMES HOME.
IF THE HELICOPTER LEFT US,
I'M PRETTY SURE WE WOULD
HAVE BEEN USING OUR,
UH, OUR SURVIVAL BAGS.
TOMORROW, WE TRY AGAIN.
AND HOPE FOR A
BIT MORE SUNSHINE.
♪ ♪
MAJOR MCCOLL: I SEE
THE WEATHER IS CHANGING.
THIS IS DUE TO A, UM, A
LOW-PRESSURE AREA STARTING IN
THE ROSS SEA, AND IT'S
DRAGGING SOME COLD AIR UP
FROM THE SOUTH POLE.
WITH THE LOW CLOUD COMING
THROUGH INTO THE OPEN POSITION
THERE'S A LOT MORE
ENERGY IN THE WIND.
THIS IS OUR BEST PROTECTION
FOR OUT ON THE ROSS ICE SHELF.
AND THEY'RE
DRIVING STRAIGHT INTO IT.
DR. OHNEISER: THE
MAIN THING IS YOU JUST
HAVE TO BE PATIENT.
YOU CAN'T
GUARANTEE THE WEATHER,
BECAUSE IT'S NOT YOU THAT
MAKES THE DECISIONS HERE,
IT'S ANTARCTICA.